ich bin letztens von London bis nach
Istanbul nur mit dem Zug gefahren für
die ganze Strecke habe ich ungefähr eine
Woche gebraucht los Dings am Montag
morgen von London bis Paris mit dem
Eurostar ein richtig geiler Zug da bin
ich erste Klasse gefahren habe mich 317
€ gekostet aber ich war schon in
zweieinhalb Stunden in Paris in Paris
angekommen habe ich mir dann erstmal die
First Class Lounge vom TGW angeschaut
bevor es mich am Nachmittag weiterhin in
der ersten Klasse im TGW von Paris bis
nach Zürich spät abends angekommen in
Zürich habe ich mir Verpflegung gekauft
für meinen Nachtzug der fuhr nämlich
abends ab um 21 Uhr von Zürich bis nach
Wien am Dienstag Morgen um 7 Uhr also ca
24 Stunden nachdem ich losgefahren bin
bin ich angekommen in Wien am
Hauptbahnhof und war erstmal komplett
fertig mit der Welt weil die Nacht eine
absolute Katastrophe war und ich nur
Schnarcher in meinem nachtzugabteilung
hatte
der Nachtzug hat mich übrigens 125 Euro
gekostet weitere zwei Stunden später
ging es für mich weiter mit dem Railjet
bis nach Budapest wo ich dann erstmal ja
gegen ca Mittag angekommen bin und mir
ein Hotel genommen habe weil ich absolut
fertig war und ordentlich schlafen
nachholen musste wenn ihr wissen wollt
ihr es weitergeht folgt mir unbedingt